سيداتي يا سادتي انساتي اينما كنتم
تتابعوننا اينما كنتم تشاهدوننا الليله في
مسرح تقام مباراه قمه نور بين المريخ
والارض بين الكوكب الاحمر والكوكب الازرق
بين الاول الذي شغل الناس هو الثاني فمن
شغل عقول الناس اتبدا مع الارض الاربعه
الارضيه الى انطلاق هي
تاتي الى المريخ عربيه راسيات
وتحديدا بالع
رب
سجل في مرمرهم
البركان اكبر البراكين
في الهند اول
تمرير
الى انطلاق ومرور
خطير انتهى الشوط الاول وواحد للمريخ فلا
شيء الارض اتت الى من الى سته الانطلاقه
الى مرور
ربهم
الله يا
ولد روعه الله
تعادل الكفه
المريخ يريد ان يعدل ان يريد ان ينتصر
يريد ان يفوز كما هي الارض انطلاقه ومرور
التحكيلات ثلاثه
ارضيه سته راسيه سته ولا غيره
الله يا سته ار امها
عاجلوها فقال
عليهم هات اثنين واحد حتى الان المريخ
يريد الاكبر مساحه في الارض السته هي مطره
السته
من مكان قريب
التسديده جول
وفازت وقلبتها على المريخ اذن
انا عالمي تعليق الكره القدم انتم مش
عالمكم شكرا